- [Narrator] This bright, colorful temple,
located in southern India,
wasn't put on earth just to catch the eye.
It's also one of the largest
Hindu houses of worship.
Welcome to the Sri Ranganathaswamy Temple.
(slow hip hop music)
It is dedicated to the
Hindu god of Ranganatha,
a reclining form of
the Hindu deity Vishnu.
But this relaxed-looking god is one of the
highest levels of Hindu idols.
The temple, which has
over six miles of walls
and over 100 buildings,
is one of the five
important pilgrimage sites
along the river Kaveri,
for devotees of Ranganatha.
The temple itself is a beacon of the
uniquely South Indian Dravidian
style of architecture.
Its temples are adorned
with pyramid-shaped towers
made from sandstone,
soapstone, or granite.
The first construction on this site
dates back nearly 700 years.
It grew and grew into the
wonder that it is today,
a site that will surely settle
any pilgrim's wandering soul.
(bing)